ryan johnson is hands down one of my
favorite people
out there so what is something that
he did for you on set as an actor's
director that made him stand out from
other directors you've worked with ryan
johnson is one of my favorites as well
and he doesn't have an ego he just knows
what he wants he
allows freedom of creativity for all of
the actors on set
um and he's also just a very genuinely
nice human being
um so much love to ryan johnson and
everything that he does
um i i remember you know talking about
kind of freedom and being a lovely human
being he noticed that
um in between scenes that i was in that
i would go behind the cameras and that i
would watch
um what other people were doing and also
the setups of different shots
and that that's something that i've kind
of been doing more and more i think
just because i really like it and i'm
curious like how things work but he saw
that i was doing that so
he would almost always make sure that
there was a place for me to be
in between setups like next to him
behind him to go and watch
what was happening and that to me like
was really really special because
again he's an incredible director he's
also incredibly busy
directing and doing everything so to
even think of
having a place and just kind of letting
me watch his work was really special
and um yeah a really great memory as
though i
couldn't like him more than i already
did that makes me even happier so
if you're super interested in the behind
the scenes stuff in the setups what was
it like watching steve yedlin work
because
i i can't process what goes through his
brain he's incredible
i love that you love stevie yeah they
have such a
kind of synonymous language i think i
was talking to him about how he made his
own color palette or something like when
when you set up a shot
please so the camera can identify it's
like on your iphone if you click
this here it's probably quite bright but
then like if
you click that it will be dark and then
the rest will be yeah so he i think
told me about how he created his own
palette and i just thought that was very
cool
um but yeah there was a really great
atmosphere on set and not
not too dissimilar to actually
spontaneous like brian was also
very freeing and fun and just like had
his parameters of okay like let's get
the job done but also
i want this to be a creative space and i
think when you can get the best of both
worlds
i mean that's that's
you